credo che il trash sia arrivato a un
certo punto dove giocare normale alle
cose è diventato futile diventiamo
stupidi ancora di più in che modo
ve lo faccio vedere io allo ragazzi sono
soggetti gli over it e già questo non è
proprio il dante alighieri dei
videogiochi avere questo abbiamo capito
o un martello grosso credo che allora il
gioco in sé è già difficile fare questo
l'abbiamo capito però ho visto che
esistono delle mode come avete potuto
vedere dal video col signor gatto che ho
fatto in multiplayer si può i giovani
getting over it si può dare eco il fatto
è da quando ho scoperto questa cosa mi
si è aperto un mondo di cose che ancora
non ho fatto su getting over it appunto
avere il martello grosso questo qua non
è un video di di quei siti che guardate
di notte voi no no questo video di
youtube da perche vi e martello grosso
io posso capire che non è se non si è
porco al demonio
posso capire che miscelano patite facile
da capire però dovete capirlo che
effettivamente i martelli grossi possono
avere un'utilità in certe situazioni
tipo questa appunto che voi dite ma è
fare ovviamente se il martello e grosso
gioco è più facile cura perché valuti
ficile farlo roteare su marte non so se
si è visto poi ti incastri nelle robe
che un piacere non è per niente facile
ragazzi genova sicuro
eccolo teoricamente io non ci dovrei
neanche passare da qua perché non ci
passa non ci passa il martello giusto
provare i fond credo che ci siano delle
situazioni che posso gestire di più col
martello gigante e situazioni che posso
gestire di meno la prima sapete tutti
che in alto qua c'è la parte successiva
solo che veramente in alto forse col
martello allungato ci posso arrivare non
lo so porco il demonio farlo girare
veramente un casino ci sono non ci sono
più
sapevo che sto sempre sarebbe stato un
casino perché ormai che ti ngo dritto in
normale lo so fare sesso a fare più o
meno però eccolo ci sono porca vacca
casino ok ora aggrappati perfetto questo
volevo meraviglioso o vedi che non è
difficile credo è di aver sbloccato un
passa a no no perché devo passargli la
aspetta devi girare allora devi girare
poi ri aggrapparti di nuovo
devo ridurre
e ridimensionare perfetto no dieci
sarebbero bravissimo e fatica e dove
sapevate ma vedo che sono finite qua va
già bene qua già bene ok fermo di su
fermo fermi mobili immobili e mobili
bene allora ok
piano piano vai via madonna ok a posto
ora forse se oculo mano culo che novità
andiamo al punto più avanti per continuo
di nuovo il martello gigante da che
secondo me non ci arriverò mai
s'incastra in nelle cose quindi arrivo
arrivo un po più avanti ragazzi impedovo
ok
beh mica ce l'ho fatta allora
ridimensioniamo un po troppo o meno un
po meno un po meno un po meno come dice
ora cavalca va bene prova a salire
esatto di qua non sono mai salito di qua
però dall'altra parte non lo spazio
quindi per forza di quando sarete fermi
e non lo spazio bianco porca vacca
ecco lo ridimensiona aiuto erano chrome
che mi è arrivato un subscriber mi sono
cagato nelle mutande perfetto ed è molto
difficile ha già fatto questo cioè
figura di devi provare ad andare
non è vero di l'anno milan allunga il
martello troppo allora va bene va bene
va bene o di un po meno a porca vacca
sai che stai la 6 aggrappati a quel
corpo e va bene ok io ce l'ho fatta
giocatore sta diventando un ragazzo
terribile perfetto no no no vai a
sinistra si sa bravo bravo caffè allora
siamo arrivati più o meno al punto dove
diceva qua è difficile perché se sbaglio
kadokawa provino samente quindi se
sbaglio è un problema allora eccoci qua
perfetto io mi posiziono qua
direttamente spostati perfetto e da qui
proviamo a salire io non so quanta la
prova a salire prima prima qui
se devo cancellarmi non mi aggancio
scherzavo perfetto non so se riuscirò a
fare questa che ci provo ti prego fa che
funzioni ok
[Musica]
sono fermo dove cup dove dove si andò
dove siamo finiti ragazzi è veramente
troppo di molto più difficili quello che
pensavo e mappe e vabbè maledizione cosa
ti amo non avevo mai visto da parte di
del gioco già siamo arrivati a più punti
inesplorati
mio dio più di questo centro dicendo
l'inizio praticamente ecco siamo
arrivati ad un punto dove ormai non la
mia rabbia ha raggiunto dei livelli sono
nel nirvana adesso cioè per me non è
niente questo la mia vita ha vissuto
momenti molto peggiori quel allora dios
mia ecco perfetto già beccato un
serpente in partenza non c'è un modo per
salire col serpente sarebbe bellissimo
non esiste tutto questo gioco una
menzogna
porca vacca è stato bellissimo questo
fatto come ho fatto a fa sta roba
ci sono dei modi se ti allunghi col
martello che in qualche modo i fan
salire ma non so come perfetto perfetto
propulsione dove siamo finiti ai beh se
non altro almeno in un punto normale
ciclo finito
non so come madonna e vabbè
quando guardo aiuto per madonna ma ci ho
messo una visita per ritornare qua
ragazzi veramente non sono diventato
scarso c'è una volta ero molto più bravo
sta roba
per questo la dice lunga su come mai io
l'ho fatto successo è diventato
veramente un inferno fare il suo gioco
devo arrivare alla seconda parte per
fare tutto molto più vivi ma niente non
c'è stato verso come su due ora tornare
qua allora sapete che vi dico arrivo la
seconda parte normalmente perché
arrivarci col martello gigante è
impossibile poi switch sul matteo
sperando di arrivarci
ok ragazzi allora devo arrivare fin
sopra la torre quindi è un bel pezzo per
poi fare la seconda parte però non so se
ci riesco cioè spero di sì perché questa
parte molto difficile anche senza cioè
questa parte non riesco a farla
normalmente quindi io spero di riuscirci
per farlo devo fare pianissimo
e se ci arrivo possiamo continuare il
video nella seconda parte che sarà a
questo punto col martello fatto
gigantesco procedeva arrivare
normalmente quello il problema
fino a qua ok qua e qua e diventa un
casino ragazzi che io più o meno se
posso darmi un aiutino qua forse devo
stare zitto sono fatta ce l'ha fatta
perfetto allora devo arrivare all altra
parte non so se ci riesco ad arrivare
con questo farlo in fretta solo di fare
fallo in fretta falli in fretta falli in
frettissima bravo oddio ovvero dove vado
porco demonio dove sta andando
non è vero sono caduto che casino mi
basterebbe rigirarmi normalmente se mi
girassi normalmente avrei fatto già un
bel peso o questo volevo
[Musica]
no